oh
get your diet culture bingo cards ready
folks hey everyone i'm abby sharp
welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video we'll be taking a look
at former playboy bunny holly madison
but first let me tell you about my
sponsor build bar it is snack time in my
house and i am super excited because
today i've got a brand new box of puff
build bars
birthday cake flavor i mean everything
is more fun when it's birthday cake
flavor
i can hear the sprinkles oh yeah
let's get in there
it's like a unicorn
guys the white chocolate just hits
different they're honestly like a
marshmallow had a party and then like
fell into a chocolate pool and somehow
what came out was a bar with 16 grams of
protein and if you really want to make
your day pair this with some oatmeal or
fruit for breakfast or put it on top of
some ice cream
and that's a party so if you want to try
out these build bars yourself check out
the link in my description and use my
promo code abbysharp15 to get 15 off of
your order and you can pause the screen
or look at the description to check out
my disclaimer including a trigger
warning to those with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating as always please feel free to
skip this video if it's not supportive
to your journey and if you are not
already subscribed hit that subscribe
button and don't forget to follow me on
tik tok and instagram so much fun
content there as well don't forget about
it okay raise your hands in the comments
if you used to watch the girls next door
i mean if that wasn't a sign of how
toxic the 2000s were i don't know what
is but holly's back and she's on youtube
and she's doing what i eat in a day
content so obviously your girl had to
respond let's do it just
went out and picked a lemon for lemon
water because it's good to drink a glass
of lemon water every morning
it's alkalizing it's good for you got a
little bit of vitamin c i am going to
age myself 10 years and get wrinkles no
amount of botox can fix just from
repeating myself so
many times folks lemon water does
provide a bit of vitamin c around 12 of
the recommended intake from the juice of
half of a lemon but
nothing i repeat
nothing we eat or drink can alkalinize
your blood or change your body ph the ph
of our blood is very tightly regulated
period exclamation point the end the
popular wellness culture concept is
somewhat grounded in the fact that lemon
is technically an acidic food but it
creates alkaline byproducts once it's
metabolized in the body but that just
means that it creates alkaline pee not
alkaline blood and not an alkaline body
it changes our literal waste product
because like we don't need it otherwise
so if you like the flavor of lemon water
great drink up but it's not a
magic morning tonic so it's january i'm
recovering from like a really bad
december eating wise i was a mess i'm
like perma bloated from it anyway so i'm
starting my day with a green smoothie i
can totally understand that it can be
challenging to navigate the post-holiday
food guilt especially if you struggle
with your relationship with food and are
bombarded with diet culture messaging to
start fresh in january but if your
annual pattern looks like overeating at
the holiday festivities then restricting
heart in january
you are bound to be back to the chaotic
eating by valentine's day so if holly's
integrating smoothies into her day as a
way to add in some extra nutrition and
help get her digestion back to a good
place then i think that's great
smoothies can be a super nutrient dense
meal or snack and if you suffer from
bloating they may help you get in some
of your vegetables with less discomfort
because the blender essentially kind of
pre-digests some of those fibers but
emotional denial and punishment will
only keep you on the binge restrict
roller coaster even longer and i got the
idea for green smoothies from this book
well not originally but when i went
through like my second green smoothie
phase i love this book the beauty detox
solution i read it right before my first
pregnancy and this book will scare you
away from eating any food besides fruit
and vegetables it's pretty
extreme but i still take inspiration
from the green smoothie recipe in here i
don't follow it exactly yikes
hell no any diet that scares you is a
major red flag
as is a diet that helps you essentially
diet during pregnancy what the actual
undernutrition during pregnancy can lead
to a series of health complications for
baby including low birth weight pre-term
delivery difficulty breastfeeding
increased risk of chronic disease later
on in life and it may also stunt brain
development in short pregnancy is never
the time to go on a diet hard stop
i'm gonna throw in a banana and then i
always do one more piece of fruit i'm
gonna do a pair today sometimes i do an
apple
so the recipe is enough to make like
almost two full smoothies that's
not a lot like so while this smoothie is
rich in fiber and micronutrients it has
like a little bit of protein it's only
got
160 calories and that's it and could
definitely use more protein carbs fat
and calories in general this is a very
small snack like this is not a meal in
my books and if losing weight is one of
holly's goals we actually have ample
evidence suggesting that a high protein
breakfast can support weight loss as it
helps to regulate appetite throughout
the day by lowering our hunger hormone
grayline and increasing our fullness
hormone leptin so if it were my smoothie
i would want to see some full fat greek
yogurt in there some nut butter hemp
hearts soy or pea milk or some silken
tofu if the green smoothie isn't enough
to make me feel full then i'll usually
have like a handful of this keto cereal
catalina crunch or a piece of
gluten-free toast
so yeah no this is not going to keep you
full and there is a little protein boost
in the cereal like about 11 grams not so
much on the toast front since
gluten-free breads tend to have less
protein than conventional breads so just
about like a gram per slice also these
additions are still pretty low calorie
even in combination with the smoothie
like max we're looking at a 250 calorie
meal so yeah it's definitely not for me
though i would love to see some nut
butter and seeds on the toast and some
milk banana and berries added to the
cereal she could even do my little hack
of mixing some protein powder into the
milk to just boost that up as well so
before i finish my smoothie i'm going to
do my
supplements i already took a probiotic i
also take iron because i'm anemic
i take nadh for energy
i take flaxseed oil
[Music]
vitamin d because i'm low vitamin d dhea
this helps keep your hormones in check
folate for like female health don quai
also for female health magnesium
because my psychic said so
and also vitamin c
psa folks psychics are not dietitians
but anyway lots to unpack here so i'm
going to try to be succinct obviously
probiotics have some benefits for gut
health but considering that holly is
struggling with bloating it's important
to keep in mind that depending on the
cause of the bloating some probiotic
strains may actually make things worse
generally speaking research suggests
that multi-strain probiotics that
contain
lactobacillus and bifidobacterium
strains may be the best bet for
persistent bloating but you definitely
want to work with a registered dietitian
to determine what is the best strain or
multi-strain for you as for vitamin c
folate and magnesium unless there's a
unique health concern supplementation is
generally not needed for the general
population if you're consuming a varied
diet so for example you can easily meet
your daily recommendation for vitamin c
from eating just like one orange or half
a bell pepper folate is key to
supplement during pregnancy but
otherwise it's found in abundance in
things like whole grains dark leafy
greens legumes nuts seeds and some
fruits however we do have some research
to suggest that magnesium may help to
combat bloating and water retention
especially during that time of the month
and it may also help to relieve mild
constipation so from that perspective
taking a supplement may help to ease any
bloating or digestive issues that holly
may be struggling with it's also
important to note that there are several
types of magnesium that serve different
functions but most of the research
suggests that magnesium hydroxide
sulfate and citrate may be most
effective for digestive distress and on
the topic of vitamin c considering that
holly did mention she's anemic we would
want to make sure that we're pairing
those iron-rich foods that we are
getting with a food source of vitamin c
as this is going to help to enhance the
iron absorption the only other thing
that we would maybe need to keep in mind
here is that calcium can inhibit the
absorption of iron so when taking those
iron supplements we just want to avoid
consuming any calcium-rich foods like a
lot of spinach or dairy at the same time
as for dhea we do have some evidence to
suggest that supplementation may support
sexual function and fertility but we
only really see this in folks with low
dhea levels in other words most young
healthy individuals with normal dhea
levels do not necessarily need to
supplement with more now moving on to
nadh and dong kwai the evidence here is
definitely
pretty pathetic nadh is promoted as
helping a wide range of ailments but we
really only have a small study to
support its use with chronic fatigue
syndrome and the results were mostly
anecdotal and not clinically significant
likewise one small study suggested that
don quai may help to ease menstrual
cramps but the results were also not
significant and 54 of participants still
needed painkillers so i mean if it helps
her it's worth a try but it also might
not lastly vitamin d supplementation is
generally best practice especially if
you're not getting enough from the sun
or from food so flaxseed oil can be a
great way to get your omega-3s if you
don't already obtain them from things
like fatty fish walnuts flaxseed and
chia seeds but keep in mind that flax
oil supplies ala omega-3s which have a
poor conversion factor to epa and dha
which are the biologically active forms
so all in all supplementation is highly
individualized and will depend on the
intended use and diet but it's super
important to speak to your family doctor
or dietitian and not a psychic just
saying to help you choose the right
supplement for you so for lunch i'm just
gonna make like a two egg scramble
with some chili lime cholula
and
organic tortilla
make a little breakfast burrito type
thingy i would usually like saute some
onions or peppers too but i don't have
them today so we're gonna do it simple
style okay i am glad we're getting some
protein in the eggs but it's still not
seeming like a lot only 15 grams and
while holly didn't have any peppers or
onions to like throw in she could opt to
add some of the spinach that she was
using in the smoothie or have some fruit
on the side for some fiber i also would
love to see some extra fat here and if
she had an avocado it could totally do
double duty as fiber and fat too i'm
still drinking lemon water i try and do
about a gallon a day so getting some in
with lunch do you need to drink a gallon
of water a day to stay hydrated no no
you don't so while it is definitely
important to stay hydrated throughout
the day our hydration needs are highly
individualized and will often fluctuate
based on climate perspiration activity
level and diet and the best way to
assess your hydration status is by
taking a peek in the toilet sitting on
the toilet
so ideally a light yellow kind of
lemonade-like color is a really good
indicator that you are solidly hydrated
most of us are just like too damn busy
to need to pee every 10 minutes or so so
you don't need to overdo it also the
thought of drinking a gallon of lemon
water like
hurts my sensitive teeth my dentist
would not approve for a snack i usually
want a snack when i'm on the go so i
have one of these split packs in my
purse
or a kind bar i think that these are
both really great on the go snack
options with a good balance of some
protein fat and fiber and i love that
they're portable enough that you can
just keep in your bag for like any time
you get hangry when i'm eating with my
kids and they're eating something that's
protein and vegetable based for dinner
i'll join them and have what they're
having oh i always join them but i'll
have the same thing they're having if
not if they're eating like mac and
cheese or quesadillas or something
that's a little more carb heavy i
usually just have like a amy's vegan
frozen burrito or like a lean cuisine or
something like that so i can at least
keep like my protein and my carbs in
check i get that dieting can be really
really really hard when you've got a
family who don't have the same goals as
you so i understand the temptation to
eat a completely different meal as your
kids when their mac and cheese or their
pizza doesn't fit into your plan but i
just want to remind everyone at home
with kids or who may be thinking about
having kids that they are always always
watching there's a reason why kids start
dieting by like seven or eight years old
monkey see
monkey do and when they see us skip the
bun or call ourselves bad for having a
slice of cake they internalize it they
emulate it they learn that carbs are bad
and they must be bad for eating them so
i urge parents to find ways to make a
family dinner
fit into their plan so have the mac and
cheese with some sauteed vegetables have
the pizza with a salad on the side
please try not to be sitting there
eating the
lean cuisine all by yourself
what so i gotta sit here and eat dessert
alone like i'm stephen glansberg yes and
if i'm going with like the kimberley
snyder diet advice i usually try
and not do a starch in a protein within
the same meal just because i mean
actually to tell you the truth i don't
stick with that very often i was just
thinking about the burritos and the um
lean cuisines and stuff like that so for
easier digestion you're supposed to kind
of keep your starches and your protein
separate
here we go
again
i guess you can count on a book titled
the beauty detox to peddle a lot of
bogus food combining rules so as i
discuss in my video right here
basically the ass backwards theory
behind food combining is that eating
protein and starches together puts too
much strain on our digestive system
causing a traffic jam so eating them
separately will give our digestive
system a break but
does our digestive system even need a
break no
i mean our digestive system is a
sophisticated well-oiled machine that's
able to multitask the digestion and
absorption of different nutrients from a
variety of different foods and release
the right cocktail of enzymes to do so
plus there's zero evidence to support
the theory behind food combining which
explains why it's exactly just that it's
just a theory so kudos to holly for like
ditching this stupid diet rule and just
enjoying the damn mashed potatoes at
dinner this is what it looks like i got
it all plated up on my marie antoinette
plate this dinner looks awesome and is
perfectly balanced with healthy fats and
protein from the salmon which also has
lots of iron carbs from the mashed
potatoes and fiber and micronutrients
from the broccoli i also want to note
that if salmon and other fatty fish is a
mainstay in like your regular diet then
there's likely no need for the flax oil
supplement on top especially because the
omega-3s in salmon epa and dha are more
biologically active than the ala in the
flax it's usually one of three things
it's either like a handful of this
catalina crunch i love the fruit flavor
i love like the chocolatey flavors and
the cinnamon flavor but the fruit flavor
to me tastes like tricks or fruit loops
so i love a handful of these or the
catalina crunch oreo cookies i'll have
one of those i like the mint ones too i
freeze them or i'll have like a fruit
bar and these do have sugar in it it's
hard to find a bar that's strictly just
fruit but if holly likes these desserts
great but i also just have to call out
that these are all pretty restrained low
calorie desserts and given that we are
seeing a pretty low calorie day overall
restricting one's fun food to like a
single low sugar keto cookie or a
handful of keto cereal feels
unnecessarily rigid so i like that holly
is flexible when it comes to ditching
some of those diet rules like food
combining i would love to see less focus
on lemon water and detox smoothies and
demonizing a 40 calorie fruit bar
because it has sugar in it and more on
just eating enough food to nourish and
support her needs with all that said
what are my overall thoughts on holly's
diet it's just
not enough without saying exact numbers
because ultimately it doesn't matter
let's just say she's consuming the
equivalent of my two-year-old son it's
very very hard to meet your nutritional
needs on so little food which is likely
why all those supplements are having to
be in rotation but no supplement will
give you energy as holly suggests that's
what the og source of energy food is for
calories from food calories from food is
literally the definition of body energy
not a vitamin or micronutrient these
things can all support energy metabolism
but you still need to eat enough
food and while i appreciate that holly
is relatively flexible in terms of not
strictly following the diet advice
housed in that beauty detox book there
still seems to be a tendency towards
following a very restrictive diet
interestingly holly mentioned in the
video that she was dealing with bloating
and as i discussed in my video right
here under eating is actually one of the
top reasons for bloating as it
essentially starves vital organs causing
them to atrophy and work less optimally
and it reduces our digestive outputs
this can naturally trigger a series of
digestive issues including poor gut
motility constipation
gas and you guessed it bloating i've
also got a whole video on gentle
nutrition strategies to help relieve
bloating which you can watch right here
but all of my colleagues who work
specifically in gi nutrition have told
me that when people are under eating
just eating enough calories and making
no other changes is often enough to
drastically improve their digestion and
bloat so hopefully holly gets the memo
and 86 ds the detox diet book in favor
of fueling her body and gut for optimal
health so on that note that's all that i
have for you guys today if you like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on who or what
i should review next subscribe to the
channel and i'll see you next time on
abby's kitchen bye
[Music]